you know how it is we put up a community
post asking for our esteemed audience's
opinion on a given anomalous topic and
when you give us the answers we make a
video like this responding to them it's
a perfect system it runs like clockwork
or more specifically like scp-914
the clockworks a fascinating safe class
anomaly that can transform anything
placed inside one of its chambers in a
number of exciting and sometimes
terrifying ways we asked you if the
device was in your hands how would you
use it and before we get into some of
the great answers we selected here's a
quick refresher on how the machine works
when an object is placed or entity is
placed into its first chamber the user
has the option to select one of five
settings each of which leads to a
relatively predictable result first
rough which completely destroys the item
often utterly disintegrating it and
turning it into dust there is no way to
repair such an item course is a little
less severe it dismantles the object
rather than destroys cleanly and
efficiently breaking it into its
component parts often in a manner that
would be conductive to the object's
reconstruction one to one is a setting
that replaces the object or entity with
something similar usually in size weight
or quality fine is a setting that
improves the item within reasonable
means rarely straying into anomalous
territory with these improvements and
the most mysterious and volatile setting
of all is very fine which improves the
item or entity in an unpredictable
anomalous manner sometimes to disastrous
results great so now we're all caught up
we've handed you a great power now let's
see if you can handle it with great
responsibility
sam rosenthal said i feel like it would
be interesting to put a musical
instrument like a piano through it on
very fine it would be interesting to see
what the machine would consider to be an
improvement with something so subjective
edit it would also need to be something
very high-end like a steinway ooh good
choice so that it didn't just come out
as a nicer piano putting a steinway
piano into the clockworks on the fine
setting would likely result in an
improvement making it a finer instrument
with a sweeter richer sound potentially
also changing its model from a baby
grand piano to a concert grand piano
however putting it into the machine on
the very fine setting would be more
likely to make the piano come alive
turning its legs into limbs capable of
functional locomotion and as for its
keys they kinda already resemble teeth
in a weird way so we're going to say
that's a no-brainer it's keys are
definitely turning into actual teeth
that are dripping with deadly venom
anyone else getting super mario 64
flashbacks or is that just me isaac ely
said if most of the chains binding
scp-2317 have snapped then presumably
there is remnants of the chains laying
around the foundation could combine this
material with regular chains and put it
on very fine and scp-914 to create new
ones to restrain the devourer of worlds
something that's extremely important to
remember is that the results of a very
fine transmutation are always
unpredictable upgrading the chains may
result in them literally gaining a mind
of their own and trying to imprison the
known universe and if they do simply
become better chains actually fixing
them to the devourer becomes the next
issue personally you're welcome to take
care of that one first eddie ember said
so i had a crazy thought i would put the
substance produced by scp-153 the soul
extractor through on one to one i'd be
interested to see what the clockwork
would quantify as the equivalent to a
soul i think it would be different
depending on the personality of the soul
inserted like while one person may give
their soul for love another one may give
their soul for a chocolate bar well if
the scientifically dubious 1907
metaphysical experiments of duncan
mcdougall are to be believed souls
despite being ephemeral weigh roughly 21
grams if the clockworks have a difficult
time qualitatively judging the value of
a human soul perhaps it would provide a
vaguely valuable item that weighs
roughly 21 grams little heartless sure
but what can you expect it's all cogs
gears and pulleys shane said i would be
interested in what would happen if you
took a drawing of scp-096
and put it on the one-to-one setting
would it turn into a realistic photo and
if yes then could this trigger the shy
guy to attack you i would also check
this the other way around to see if you
could get a pick of scp-096
that doesn't activate his killing spree
while it's impossible to know for sure
we personally wouldn't risk this one a
single photon of scp-096's face is
enough to activate its rage state has
the failure of dr dan's scramble goggles
prove so even if the clockwork produces
an even half-decent true representation
of 096 looking at it will give you a
truly horrifying death sentence alec
bees said i would actually somehow get a
part of scp-682's body mass and
experiment on it maybe downgrading the
682 piece by piece wouldn't let it
combine together again or maybe just
upgrade downgrade or let some parts of
682 as they were maybe 682 wouldn't be
able to adapt to this not a big chance
though anything involving scp-682 the
hard to destroy reptile is going to be
unpredictable by the very nature of the
cantankerous lizard itself the big issue
with trying to downgrade 682 piecemeal
is that each part would be likely to
reform and adapt before you had a chance
to process the rest of it xwing knight
said what happens if you put one pill
from scp-500 on very fine i would
recommend against any more because there
are not many but maybe it would
duplicate the pill because i don't know
how you'd improve it as it already cures
literally anything or maybe do it on
rough to see if it gets broken down to
its components and see if it can be
reverse engineered all we know for sure
about scp-500 and scp-914 is that on the
fine setting it results in scp-426
a locket with rejuvenating properties
the foundation are reluctant to do any
tests on scp-500 given how valuable they
are and how limited the supply is but
the very fine setting could result in
something amazing maybe a doctor capable
of curing anything you know the kind of
doctor that scp-049 wishes he was mr
arthur said it would be interesting to
put the researcher that presents the
scps on very fine maybe the machine will
make the researcher into one of the
writers of scp-001 the database
hold on
you mean me
[Laughter]
you want to put me in that thing oh you
definitely don't want to put me in the
machine at the very fine setting we'd
suddenly be capable of putting out a new
video every few minutes it'd destroy
your timelines and even if you
unsubscribed you'd still see the videos
they just keep coming there is no escape
scp explained is eternal
there is no escape
moving on dr veronica said ah it
happened my request to be hired as a
doctor at the foundation has been
accepted how about taking scp-458 the
never-ending pizza box and putting it
through on very fine i imagine that it
may be able to turn into something that
can infinitely reproduce any food you
desire failing that maybe put a
politician through on the very fine
setting will that make them a very fine
politician or a very fine person that
happens to be a politician or will it
make them senator armstrong from metal
gear rising huh pizzas and politicians
the two peas of conflicting emotions
putting scp-458 through scp-914 might
result in it turning into an entire
pizzeria that gives away perfect pizzas
at no cost they'll have wonderful
service impeccable atmosphere and always
remember your name they'll even give
away free breadsticks and exquisite
garlic bread bowls for the table along
with discounts on the finest mid-tier
wine you've ever seen it'd be divine the
politicians on the other hand could go
in one of two ways maybe they'd become a
true champion of the people guided by
ironclad principles that they'll fight
tooth and nail to see actualized doing
right by their voters and the general
public treating their office with
dignity and poise or they'll be the most
incredible silver-tongued self-serving
conniving backstabber you've ever seen
endlessly devoted to winning office in
order to monetize their position raid
the country's coffers and run off with a
fat bag of swag while the nation burns
behind them oh wait you said very fine
chances are they can shoot lasers and
are maybe 50 feet tall too that's just
kind of the thing you need to expect
although the first descriptor sounded
like a normal politician george
ciminovich said if you put
scp-1609 through on the fine setting
maybe it would restore it to its chair
form that is a possibility but given the
anomalous nature of
scp-1609 the vengeful remains of a chair
it's equally possible that it might just
become higher quality wood chips perhaps
mahogany oh that'd be real nice gustavo
abate said if you put two or more things
would they fuse into one if they do
would the machine separate them back if
programmed right i don't believe that
scp-914 would fuse multiple items or
entities that are placed into its
chamber you may be confusing that with
another anomalous technology like say a
teleporter but if a researcher is
willing to step into scp-914 with a fly
then we might be able to see for
ourselves whether we're right stupid
people said i think it would be
interesting to put one of scp-978's
photos through the fine or very fine
settings preferably one with an
interesting desire depicted like the shy
guy's desire to not exist it's unlikely
that even the clockworks would have the
ability to tangibly change reality based
on the photographs of the desire camera
however on the very fine setting the
photo will at the very least begin to
move and heck maybe something will even
crawl out that's when you'll really
regret putting any photo of
scp-096 in there the gc gamer yt said i
would insert a cake or some other type
of food on the very fine setting to see
if it would come out as a better version
of that food like a cupcake into a full
cake or better quality ingredients maybe
it would simply change the flavor and
we'd find out that there's some kind of
sentience behind the clockworks allowing
it to have an opinion on flavors on the
fine setting everything you've just
described is likely to be correct on the
very fine setting on the other hand the
cake may grow giant spider legs start
spewing noxious amnestic fumes and begin
attacking anyone who isn't brave enough
to eat it and end its reign of delicious
well-frosted terror happy birthday moldy
doritos said what about y909 from
scp-3000 on very fine interesting to see
an improved amnestic effect or perhaps
it changes the substance completely also
interesting if you put it through on
rough or very rough to see the output
probably just a weak anesthetic or
perhaps just rat poison on very fine the
y909 amnestic might become so powerful
that just looking at it will induce a
permanent alzheimer's like state in its
victims effectively deleting their minds
on rough it may just break the vials
it's stored in and spilled the liquid
everywhere dark mega5 said i print out a
meme put it in on the fine setting very
fine might have unforeseen consequences
and post whatever comes out for massive
amounts of reddit karma it is an
honorable plan we do it already in our
own way whenever we finish a video we
run it through scp-914 on fine just to
make sure it's at top quality and once
we did it on very fine and
we'll let you speculate as to what video
that was down in the comments bredo said
i'm actually kind of interested to see
what would happen if we put keanu
through the machine on very fine would
it just break
oh braido how can you improve on
perfection solrex the sun king said put
my character sheet for dnd into it on
very fine and just see what happens just
uh make sure the alignment is changed to
neutral or better before doing so on
verifying it's likely that scp-914 would
ignore the content of the paper and
instead mutate the paper itself perhaps
it would turn itself into a deadly paper
plane flying around and blasting little
paper turrets and air-to-surface
missiles at its targets and that might
veer a little more into chaotic evil
territory devon underscore gaming said i
feel like putting in one of my model
tanks to see how it looks in the very
fine setting it's unlikely that those
model tanks would remain models for long
they may wind up full-sized fully
autonomous and chasing you down the
foundation halls firing lasers and
radioactive payloads they might even
receive air support from the paper plane
riley mushil said what happens when you
put water in and set it too very fine
would it become water from the fountain
of youth or would it become the best
tasting water ever on very fine the
water may become a nightmarish
aggressive creature that actively seeks
out and destroys its human victims like
scp-3280 also known as after the storm
though if we're extremely lucky maybe
life-giving anomalous water is in the
cards we just don't like to be overly
optimistic these days we've been burned
too many times wild night studios said i
would input the tickle monster in it and
turn the setting to fine allowing the
tickle monster's power to make scp-682
docile forever while it's too much of a
risk to ever try putting scp-999 into
914 if things went well 999 may become
so powerful that we'd never experience
sadness or anger on earth again and
after everything we've been through
wouldn't that be a nice reprieve joey
rolfe said i would put in one of the o5
council on very fine setting then they
would make better choices because
they're better than before don't let
them know we said this but personally we
don't think the members of the o5
council should be getting any more
anomalous superpowers aren't they
ambiguously dangerous and powerful
enough already dysfunctional dragonborn
said i'd put an nft into it on very fine
in hopes it turns into something of
value
you genuinely caught me by surprise
there with that one however
doing this might make their insidious
power grow even stronger rather than
worthless jpegs they might instead
become a rival group the nft foundation
which instead of protecting humanity
from evil instead decides to display a
level of evil that rivals even the
malice of the scarlet king it's really
not worth finding out chosen mosin said
i'd put my resume in turn it to very
fine and see if i can eventually get
hired in my college town this is a high
risk high reward move putting your
resume in on very fine may make it a
document that immediately anomalously
convinces potential employers that you
would be the perfect candidate it may
push things further and make your
prospective employers obsessed with you
they follow you home and watch you
through your windows they wish to take
care of you they wish to be wed to you
they will never leave you alone after
all it was an excellent resume swagger
said i think putting hideo kojima in the
very fine setting would show something
very interesting if you run kojima
through the clockworks on very fine he
might even be powerful enough to design
and release silent hills on his own no
we're still not over that is anyone
hearth fireheart said a titanium
prosthetic arm put in on very fine
predicted result of possible prosthetic
arm with anomalous properties or an
enhanced titanium prosthetic that can
move exactly like a regular arm while
granting enhanced strength we're always
down for super powered robot arms
chances are on very fine and might even
get shape-shifting or immensely powerful
reality warping abilities so powerful it
may even begin to change the rest of
your body picture what happens to tetsuo
in akira bunker said put a burger on the
very fine setting i'm very curious as to
what would happen to something as simple
as a burger all we'll say is we
definitely don't recommend eating the
burger after you've run it through it
may wind up eating you from the inside
once you're done deez said i would put
raw steak in the machine and put it on
very fine that way the steak will taste
very delicious and be very fine
[Music]
i'm beginning to sense that people were
just getting hungry when they started
sending these ones in and we definitely
don't think you should put a stake into
scp-914
for all we know it might turn into
scp-058 and get us all killed nicholas
lau said alright this will sound
disgusting i toss in a jar of some of my
own toenails hair dandruff spit and
tears then cover the jar in lead paint
put on a sticker saying warning
radioactive materials and come in with a
hazmat suit and a lead shield put on
fine then evacuate the room for the
object to appear okay
well that's one of the most revolting
answers we've ever received here on scp
explained well done nicholas it's going
to be a while until we can get this
thought out of our heads this is the
exact opposite of very fine and the only
person thrilled by this answer is my
therapist ray parentel said a nickelback
cd on very fine just like we said for
keanu earlier how could you improve on
perfection and there you have it folks
thanks again to everyone who sent in
their fascinating and
disturbing answers if you want to be in
the next video like this keep an eye on
our community tab and thank you for your
continued support you'll always be very
fine to us now go check out how to
actually beat scp-3008 the infinite ikea
and scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories for more of the weirdest and
wildest responses from the scp-explained
community